it is great to welcome to the program
today dr. John Gartner who is the
founder of duty to warn and co-editor of
Rocketman nuclear madness and the mind
of Donald Trump he also taught in the
Department of Psychiatry at Johns
Hopkins Medical Center for 28 years so
let's sort of go to the beginning if we
can I mean what when we're talking about
an analysis of a public figure
like Donald Trump what can be deduced
without an in-person examination and and
what cannot because this has been a big
issue in terms of the sort of mental
health assessments to call them
something that have been done of the
president yeah actually we can infer
just about everything what people don't
understand is that the personal
interview was not the gold standard of
psychiatric assessment especially if
you're dealing with a liar if you're
dealing with a liar doing an interview
is that may not even be that helpful
because they're not motivated to give
you honest information they're not
they're not a valid or an honest
reporter in fact we changed our
diagnostic system in 1980 when we
adopted the Diagnostic and Statistical
Manual and the main reason we changed it
was to have diagnostic criteria that
were based on observable behaviors in
the past had been based on Freudian
psychoanalysis which was very
speculative but the DSM is based on
observable behaviors so if I can observe
your behavior or if I can talk to
someone who can observe your behavior I
can form a valid diagnosis and when it
comes to Donald Trump to sort of get us
into that conversation what are the
conditions or diagnosis that you believe
can be accurately made again without the
in-person interview which you've just
sort of described why that's not
ultimately completely necessary right
one of the reasons that Donald Trump is
so dangerous is he actually suffers from
multiple conditions but the first one
that I want to talk about is something
called malignant narcissism it's a
personality disorder that was first
introduced by Erich Fromm who escaped
the Nazis in 1934 to explain the
psychology of dictators what he called
the essence of
evil and it has four components
narcissism of course the only I can fix
it and I and he knows more about
everything than everyone but also
paranoia
so his crazy conspiracy theories and his
demonization of the press of the
opposition of minorities of immigrants
and this constant feeling that he's a
victim and that he's aggrieved an
antisocial personality disorder
sometimes called sociopath II so this is
someone who routinely lies who violates
and exploits the rights of other people
who has no remorse over the harm that he
causes who violates norms and laws so
really this is the criminal personality
these are predators without a conscience
and then finally the fourth component is
sadism actually enjoying harming other
people so for example with the zero
tolerance policy the cruelty was not a
bug it was a feature there was actually
an element of pleasure that he gets from
crushing weaker people underneath his
boot like a bully Erich Fromm told us
two things want three things one this is
the essence of evil the closest
psychiatry can come to defining the
human monster secondly they get worse
over time not better and remember when
everyone was so optimistic that he was
going to pivot I think our become more
presidential
what would Eric Frome taught us is that
in fact these types of personalities get
dramatically worse once they gain
political power when you went in to pick
on just one of those areas there when we
consider the effect of these traits of
these conditions on specifically the job
of president what are the ways that to
you are are sort of standing out in
terms of where we should be most
concerned is it the obvious like this
guy could launch nuclear weapons or is
it sort of more pedestrian and
day-to-day than that well I think we
need to be worried at every level I mean
how did Hitler affect Germany you know
he destroyed the country and and
millions of people innocent people in
the process yes we do need to be worried
about nuclear war malignant narcissistic
leader is almost always do star
Wars they do it to expand their
grandiosity because they feel they
should be kings of the world they do it
because they're paranoid so they think
they're under attack or they perceive
themselves as being under attack and
because they are sadistic they actually
enjoy in a very perverse way the process
of creating mass destruction these are
malevolent people these are actual
people who revel in destruction so
there's that
so we yes we do need to worry about his
making a nuclear decision either Erich
Fromm's that these people actually verge
on the delusional so they have grandiose
delusions they have paranoid delusions
so he might actually make a decision
about nuclear war in a state of
psychosis responding to a delusion and
not even to reality then we have to add
the fact that he's also in a state of
cognitive decline if you look at the
interviews that he gave in the 1980s he
spoke and polished paragraphs he was
able to finish the sentence he showed
her a very high level of vocabulary now
his vocabulary has shrunk dramatically
he can hardly finish a sentence without
D bailing into an irrelevance II he
repeats himself over and over again he
over uses superlatives all of these are
signs that we see in people who have an
organically based cognitive decline so
he's not demented but he might is
probably in a state we call pre dementia
where someone is declining but they
haven't hit the bottom of the hill yet
so the other issue is that he might not
even be cognitively able to understand
all the issues that might be happening
in a nuclear crisis you look at how
Kennedy handled the nuclear missile
crisis one of our writers talks about
that and the complexity and the
sophistication and the empathy he had
used for his opponent to be able to find
a face-saving solution that avoided
nuclear war but we also have to worry
about him in other contexts you know the
the ztp policy if it hadn't been stopped
by you know out the out roar of the
public his plan was to separate hundreds
of thousands of children from the
parents and put them in camps in
concentration camps the original meaning
of concentration camp was not a death
camp
it the original meeting is to
concentrate a portion of the population
that you think is undesirable because of
their race or their religion or their
beliefs to separate them from the
general population and concentrate them
in some other place so now we've taken
these people who are applying for asylum
these poor Hispanic immigrants and we've
demonized them and to save America from
there you know criminal activity and
they're raping we need to isolate them
in these camps and separate them from
their children ya know I think doing
I think people to not dig so much into
the policy per se because I think you
know we've discussed that quite quite a
bit I think the most interesting angle
for our audience would be sort of the
the medical component here there will be
people who say that that there is
something irresponsible about saying
that these are the conditions which this
person has that in the same way that you
can point to the seeming disdain for
hispanic immigrants as indicative of a
condition which might jeopardize his
ability to be president others might say
he sees that as a necessary means to the
end which is protecting the country it's
not my view I know it's not your view
but but let's let's address that head-on
because there will be people who hear
this and they'll say that that there's
something irresponsible about going
ignoring the Goldwater rule making the
diagnosis not having interviewed the
individual and and advocating for the
removal of the president on that basis
how can we in an objective way address
that concern because much of these
diagnosis is at least through media
there's a subjective element to even
though of course you are a medical
professional and the other people that
you're working with are as well
there is some element of subjectivity
when it's coming through media actually
I have to disagree okay because first of
all I've observed more abdominal Trump's
behavior than all of my psychotherapy
patients put together hmm so I meet them
in my office for an hour a week I know
what they tell me about their life and
Donald Trump's case I'm observing his
behavior directly
I guess a bounder to that words I'm
reading his words directly yeah
Twitter and one of the things we use in
psychiatry is what we call significant
others who give reports and we have
dozens of people who are close to the
president who work with the president
who are on his team who have leaked to
people in the media that they are wildly
concerned about his mental stability
yeah the begs more relevant to me that's
what that that actually to me is is much
more relevant for our conversation and
again to be clear I don't disagree with
what you're saying but I want to be
thorough on the basis of what I know the
feedback will be when we've done these
interviews before could someone say
listen when Trump is speaking to the
press that's not Donald Trump the person
necessarily it's a character of sorts
when Donald Trump is giving an interview
on camera that is a character of sorts
because he knows that he's being filmed
what what about that argument how do we
address that head-on well look Donald
Trump is a liar but he tells two kinds
of lies one are the lies that any
competent con man tells to deceive other
people and so when you say he's playing
this role and he's saying the brush's a
hoax and this is fake news you could
just simply say he's a psychopath who's
lying who's trying to manipulate us and
so this entire caricature or this little
persona is just an act in and of itself
by the way that would still make him a
highly dangerous demagogue one of the
writers in our book presents a
wonderfully compelling case that argues
against what some of the other authors
saying is she's saying he's not mad he's
he's not a madman he's following the
strong man's playbook that in other
words kind of a different version of the
Erich Fromm argument but saying that he
is a authoritarian dictator and this is
how authoritarian dictators manipulate
their societies to erode democracy so if
that's the best-case scenario that's
pretty bad that is still pretty bad that
is still very bad would actually is
actually psychotic and he's actually
delusional and he actually does
know that what he's saying is his ally
because he lives in his own reality I
think that both are true about Donald
Trump that he that he is somewhat
fluidly goes back and forth between
simple lies like he told in Helsinki
when he argued that you know he'd
believed Putin that Putin didn't
interfere in the election when we're
gonna find that he and Putin planned
interference in the election so that's
just a simple lie but a my friend but a
very important one but when he says
things like he had the biggest crowd
sighs that sounds like a grandiose
delusion or that
Trump bugged I mean sorry that Obama
bugged his offices that sounds like a
paranoid delusion those lies didn't help
him in any way politically they actually
hurt his credibility so yeah when all of
the wild conspiracy theories that he's
endorsed you have to think that this
person's capacity to actually he bends
reality to fit his narcissistic needs
and his paranoid fantasies so to what
extent is he just manipulating us into
what extent is he actually fooling
himself are actually deluded it's not
always easy to tell at any given moment
in time but he does both very briefly in
in the limited time we have left the
25th amendment is the path that more
than likely would be that if the grounds
for removal is on the basis that you and
some of your colleagues are describing
what step 1 in that path well the
problem is the twentieth amendment can
only be invoked by the cabinet and the
vice president yes and because we have a
Republican Party that is completely
corrupt and entirely invested in
colluding with Russia they will never
invoke the 25th amendment even if he was
you know wildly hallucinating and
babbling incoherently they're just that
committed to resting power at the
expense of the Constitution in the
country so they are utterly corrupt they
have no bottom they have no limit there
there is no there is no point where they
would draw the line and say enough
realistically the only chance we have to
remove him is to flood the polls in
November to create a blue wave big
enough that they can't manipulate it
with Russian hacking
or Russian influence in the voting
machines which is a great concern of
mine in order to win back Congress so
that we can actually do honest
investigations have honest oversight and
those investigations will lead to
impeachment in the end it gets back to
voting as I've been saying for four
months at this point we've been speaking
with John Gartner he is the founder of
duty to warn and co-editor of Rocketman
nuclear madness and the mind of Donald
Trump thank you so much for talking to
us about this today well thank you for
having me